parliament is set to vote on proposals
to reform the common agricultural policy
the aim is to make the cap greener
fairer and more flexible
meps will vote on the eu's 2022 budget
parliament is set to approve a funding
boost of
479.1 million euros for health youth and
climate action
parliament will discuss strengthening
the eu's pharmaceutical strategy to
avoid the medicine shortages experienced
during the pandemic meps are calling for
a patient-centered policy that supports
a more competitive and innovative
pharmaceutical industry
parliament will propose new rules to
facilitate legal migration to the eu
meps want to put an end to labor
exploitation while a european talent
pool would make it easier for employers
to find workers
as the eu transitions to a digital and
climate neutral economy demand for
critical raw materials like lithium and
tungsten will grow meps are set to call
for more sustainable and environmentally
friendly mining processing and disposal
of raw materials